silver
okay
uh El config in pages
they
empathiere
is
visitor executives
I've never repair a new Brazil
coincidence
foreign
thank you
to fight down European America
is
foreign
positive
results
foreign
if they would
I voted again
foreign
Australia
[Music]
International
foreign
leadership
a formalities
International now
foreign
[Music]
yes
thank you very much president Lula and
thank you very much for the warm welcome
I'm very glad to be here in Brasilia
and indeed president Lula you brought
Brazil back to where it belongs
as a major Global player
a leader in the Democratic world
and I'm here to tell you that Europe is
back too
Europe is back in Brazil
Europe is back in Latin America
our regions are not only natural
Partners but they are partners of choice
and it is time to take our strategic
partnership to the next level
our partnership comes of course also
with new investment we discussed that in
our bilateral talk the European Union is
already the top investor in the region
and I'm very glad to announce that we
will step up even further
through global gateway that is our
International Investment plan
the European Union will invest 10
billion euros in Latin America and the
Caribbean and this is only the start
because it will be complemented by
private Investments and by the
contributions of Our member states
we have discussed several topics you
mentioned them I want to reflect on some
of them the first is indeed the global
Challenge on which we are joining forces
is the fight against climate change
and president Luna I told you that I
heard for the first time when I heard
you speaking it was at cop27 your
inspiring speech I very much welcome
your leadership on climate and in
particular your leadership on
biodiversity
we discussed the Amazon forest the
Amazon forest that is a Wonder of nature
it's the green lung of our planet and it
is a key Ally against global warming so
we want to contribute 20 million euros
to the Amazon fund of course also Our
member states will contribute
we discussed your plan to end
deforestation by 2030. this is great
news for the world
and Europe is also your partner in this
here too we would like to support you
because you have a big responsibility in
stopping deforestation in the rain
forest so we want to support you with
global gateway we have a project
together of 430 million euros to fight
deforestation and to promote indeed
which is so important sustainable land
use in the Amazon
I very much welcome Brazil's bit to host
cop 30 in belem it will be a powerful
message to bring the climate conference
to the mouth of the Amazon
Brazil is also a superpower in renewable
energy
you are probably using 87 of your
electricity from renewable sources if
you take the overall energy it's 50
percent
this is truly impressive
and we can learn a lot from you
I'm very pleased that we are launching
today another global gateway Flagship
project this is on hydrogen
with this Europe will invest 2 billion
euros to support Brazil's production of
green hydrogen
and to promote Energy Efficiency in your
industry
the second point we discussed you
mentioned it is the digital transition
and there too we start from a very good
basis
global gateway supports the new digital
alliance between our regions
it finances for example the Ella fiber
optic cable which is co-founded by
Brazil it's basically that Bridget the
digital bridge between our continents
and we also offer to work together on
your plans for the transformation of
Brazil's Agriculture and Manufacturing
in digitizing it this is a field where
we also want to join forces together
the European Union and Brazil also share
the same values
in the digital world
we agreed that our rules on artificial
intelligence or on data must put the
right of people first
and we know that this information is a
threat to our societies and to our
democracies
and we agree to connect our efforts to
counter it
so there's a lot we can do to succeed in
our climate and digital transitions
for these transitions
we need critical raw materials and this
is a third area where we can step up
cooperation
we are launching a strategic partnership
on critical raw materials between the
European Union and Brazil
and this will help to meet the rising
Demand on our continents and create good
jobs here in Brazil
my fourth point it is very important it
was your first point is trade and
investment
we both believe that it is now the time
to conclude the EU marcosul agreement
we have the ambition the two of us to
get it done as soon as possible the
latest by the end of the year
I think there are huge advantages on
both sides the agreement will create the
right conditions for investment to flow
it will support as you call it the
re-industrialization of Brazil it will
help integrate and strengthen our value
chains and boost the competitiveness of
our Industries globally and it will
create good jobs in Brazil
we share the same vision of fighting
climate change as I just described and
on labor rights we discussed it and our
common commitments in these areas will
be embedded in the macrosul agreement
so this Trade Agreement is more than a
trade agreement I see it as a long-term
engagement as a platform for dialogue
and indeed
we have sent an a letter with an
additional instrument we're very much
looking forward to your answer because
it's our opening to listen to you to
listen what can be improved to listen
where we have to make a step towards
each other
so that we can indeed by the end of the
year conclude the mercosul agreement
we are strategic partners and we need to
work together to address Global
challenges this also includes Russia's
war on Ukraine because the impact of
Russia's War goes well beyond Ukraine's
border
it affects the global economy from
energy markets to food security
Brazil also felt it with difficulty of
supply of fertilizers higher energy
prices and inflation
but beyond that this war is also a
severe threat
to the principles of international law
and the U.N Charter which I know is so
very dear to Brazil it threatens the
sovereignty that is enshrined in the U.N
Charter and the territorial Integrity of
each country also enshrined in the U.N
Charter we appreciate Brazil's very
clear condemnation of this war in
multilateral fora
together with Ukraine we want a just and
comprehensive and Lasting peace
the International Community needs to
address this challenge we discussed the
peace plans that are on the table
president zelenski's peace formula that
is on the table and Brazil will have an
important role to play in the upcoming
G20 chair you can count on our full
support
to conclude
I believe this is the beginning of a new
era in the EU Brazil relations
I look very much forward to welcoming
you in Brussels I heard that you have
plans to travel and of course we are
working intensively to the select Summit
many things
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]